Good evening everyone and welcome to the fourth Luskin Lecture for
Thought Leadership. The goal of the speaker series is to give you firsthand exposure
to the thinkers who are helping to shape
the national conversation. We hope that
you will glean insights into their
thinking and strategy to understand how
our public leaders approach the
challenges and controversies of our time
As mayor of the country's third largest
city Rahm Emanuel is in a unique
position to share with us the
relationship between the prospects for
our cities and the prospects for our
country. Please join me in welcoming
Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel
You live in a period of time where you earn what you learn.
A high school degree no longer
cuts it in the 21st century we have to make
sure every child in the city of Chicago
has an educational plan that can take
them where they need to go because
that's your passport in the 21st century
it has to be universal for every child
This is from one of our MBA students...
for decades the south side of Chicago has been plagued by poverty and gun violence so what's
driving this and what do you do about it?
Look last year we were down 22 percent
on shootings it's only February but
we're down 34 percent this year
One is policing it has had an impact in
reducing the shootings
I think you've got to help create a
positive role model system for young men
Economic opportunity in a neighborhood...
you know I firmly believe kids cannot be
what they cannot see. Lastly is access to
guns.
So my view is it's part policing, mentoring, economic opportunity and access to guns.